for me the thing that i identify with  tim curry the most is probably clue  [Applause]  [Music]  he's just so mad cap and so  he runs that whole thing it's it's a  film completely existing out of control  and one of the few things that is in  control even though he's not really  handling it is the butler is tim curry  and he's so fantastic in that film  really do you know something i've  noticed over the 20 years that we've  known each other  if anybody asks you for one thing  you always give them three or four  it's true it's really hard for me to  double down on anything but i'm glad you  answered first because i was going to  say edward scissorhands because i  thought you were talking about that  director what's his name oh tim burns  yeah that's something totally different  [Laughter]  rocky horror picture show wow  what a movie  [Music]  you're shining bright i'm your voice the  baby you're my pearl